[Music]
what our achievements over the last year
we've working much closer together I
think I can say for both of us were very
proud of the way the staff have worked
with us because there's been a lot of
changes we've started to build our own
council houses for the first time in a
generation we created a new legal
service partnership the SRP is going
from strength to strength and all it
shows that we're achieving things for
our communities which is the whole
reason why we're here I don't think
there will be any changes this time
around we've only just refreshed our
joint strategic plan and at the end of
the day the priorities of those our
communities are telling if they want so
we might be tweaking them slightly but
we were those are certainly the focus of
all the work we do in the future
I think we have made huge inroads into
what we're doing as I said earlier we'll
have to worry about government funding
and how we make different money
different circumstances we've got a
couple investments and we're looking at
the business rates we've got to help our
businesses grow but life changes all the
time and we've got to be aware of that
move with it times are changing finances
are really getting worse for us so we
have to look at new ways of earning
money I think the biggest challenge will
be the financial position the council's
are in we are losing all the government
grant Louise to get business rates are
going to be fooled we need to work
together to see how we can improve our
business prepare rates and working with
our communities that's the biggest
challenge we're facing I think we have
to listen to our communities and what
they want I think there will be more
demanding they don't understand that the
finances are going down we have to make
them very aware that we have to
communicate that to them but we are part
of the Suffolk white family we do work
together very collaboratively and we
have to look at working with partners
more in order to achieve for our
communities I hope by then with we have
moved very successfully into endevour
House I hope that the staff are able to
work with this and realized why we've
done it to cut cross but to work much
more in conjunction with County which
we've got to do some
and I hope that the hubs or spokes
whatever we're going to call them in the
outside regions are working very well
that would be my main achievement the
next year
[Music]